I don't understand why anyone who's
successful would live in a place like
New York I cannot imagine why someone
like you for example who's been wildly
successful in business made a bunch of
money I can't imagine why unless you had
to for some business reason you know I
lived in New York City for a long time
because I worked you know in media you
had to be there it was horrible but why
would someone elect to live in a place
that outright comes front and center and
penalizes you for wealth penalizes you
for success as there's a separate set of
standards for you the reason they're
doing this is because there's boatloads
of people that you know you open up
their glove compartment in their car and
all that comes out are just parking
tickets that have been unpaid and most
of those people are lower income and you
know what they say they say Well they're
not going to come for me because there's
this sense in places like New York City
that they won't come for the so-called
little guy but if you're making you know
400 500 600 000 a year you're successful
oh how dare you